Narrator: If you peel back the layers
of Rapunzel's hair in "Tangled,"
you'll see just how complicated
animating 3D hair can be.
But back then, Disney had
mainly focused on straight hair,
building on its previous 2D looks.
With "Encanto," the studio figured out
how to create coiled hair like Mirabel's
with natural movement.
But the animators didn't stop there.
"Encanto" made history as the
first Disney animated movie
to represent the full
range of hair textures,
from 1A to 4C.
Getting from here to here
required over a decade of innovation.
The story begins with a
familiar storybook princess
who in 2010 was seen for
the first time in 3D.
Disney's first major foray
into 3D hair animation
came with "Tangled."
Rapunzel's 70 feet of hair
was basically its own
character in the movie,
pretty much breaking every
real-life law of motion,
and not just because it was magical.
That's a lot of hair.
She's growing it out.
Nadim: Every shot of every movie
has a lot of bending the laws of physics.
Otherwise, things would look very flat.
Narrator: This emphasizes a key tenet
of Disney's animated hair.
The goal isn't always to make it
as realistic as possible,
but rather believable
within the fictional world of the story.
To make Rapunzel's CG-animated locks
look as appealing as
Disney's hand-drawn ones,
the filmmakers started with a "hair bible"
created by artist Glen
Keane, who was behind
some of the biggest hair
hits of Disney's 2D past.
The bible set rules,
like how Rapunzel's hair
could never fall in anything
resembling a straight line.
It had to have volume;
rhythmic curves, twists, and turns;
and a signature swoop in the front.
But that shampoo-commercial hair
wouldn't be so easy to replicate in 3D.
Nadim: It's not hand-drawn,
where you're focusing
more on the shaping and you could cheat.
You have to kind of take
everything into account
when you're doing CG hair,
even stuff that's not on screen.
Narrator: Like wind or different
sources of light or shadow.
And Rapunzel's strands
interacted with the environment
in ways never seen before.
You had hair interacting with cloth,
with skin, with other hair.
The other characters were
constantly touching, pulling,
climbing, and rolling in it.
Accounting for all these interactions
would require simulation,
a way of automating
the movement of elements
like hair, fur, and cloth.
The only movie before "Tangled"
where I think we had really
even attempted simulated hair
was "Bolt" with Penny.
We knew we had a huge task ahead of us
to go from basically that
to 70-foot-long flowing hair.
Narrator: Engineers then created a program
called Dynamic Wires,
which combined physically based simulation
with laws for determining
the hair's behavior
that defied physics.
This allowed the artists
to make Rapunzel's hair
twist and turn in exactly
the ways they wanted.
In real life, this hair
would weigh 60 to 80 pounds,
so it'd clump into a mass
or drag on the ground,
like a heavy tail.
But in the movie, you see
it gliding smoothly along.
Meanwhile, to give the artists more power
to sculpt the look of Rapunzel's hair,
the team broke down her 140,000 strands
into 147 different tubes.
Michelle: The idea was
to sculpt tubes of hair
that would represent
the main blocks of hair.
That process allowed us to kind of control
the way the hair would
break apart and interpolate.
Narrator: This tube-grooming tool
was the predecessor to Tonic,
the hair-grooming software
that Disney still uses today.
Nadim: A lot of the
technology from that movie
pretty much still exists till this day
or has evolved into a newer form.
Narrator: You can see
that clearly in "Frozen,"
which had over 50 unique hairstyles.
Believe it or not, Elsa was originally
going to have black, spiky short hair.
But as the characters evolved,
Disney decided to give both Elsa and Anna
light-colored braids, in line with
the Norwegian cultural traditions
that inspired the movie.
Michelle: We were pulling
the hair from her head,
weaving it through into a
braid all the way to the end.
And just trying to ensure
that those braid pieces
didn't crash into each other
and would bend and move
properly was a challenge for us.
Narrator: For "Bolt," Disney had developed
a hair-brushing tool called iGroom,
which worked well on
short-haired characters.
But that plus the tube
tools from "Tangled"
weren't enough for braided looks,
so Disney's engineers built
a new hair-grooming system
called Tonic.
Tonic is a volume-based tool,
which lets artists group the hairs
on a character's head and move and direct
those sections of hair
in the desired ways.
This allowed look artists like Michelle
to create the first
versions of complex styles
within a few days, a process that before
would've taken several weeks.
The team was also able to use Tonic
for the hair on the wolves and horses
and the shaggy reindeer
hair on Sven's neck.
Elsa's hair had another
environmental element
to adapt to: snow.
Michelle: Particles of snow
or sparkles on top of hair
is like procedural geometry
on top of procedural geometry.
So that was hard to figure out.
Narrator: And then there
were the gusts of wind.
Michelle: Very stylized
bang shapes that, you know,
these kind of pieces that formed
that really distinctive silhouette.
She really does, towards
the end of the movie,
get blown around quite a bit,
and trying to balance
maintaining that stylization
and that kind of appealing shape language
with real physical motion.
Narrator: Figuring out hair's interaction
with the wintry elements in "Frozen"
paid off in "Moana," where the focus
was on hair's interaction
with more forces,
like water and character movements.
Things might have been
more straightforward
if the demigod Maui had been bald,
like The Rock himself,
which was the original plan.
But Polynesian cultural
advisors pointed out
that Maui's long hair is a
source of his spiritual energy,
so both Maui and Moana ended
up with long, curly-wavy hair.
I've only been thinking
of keeping this hair silky
and being awesome again.
Narrator: The first task was sculpting
their zigzag, or S-shaped, curls,
a hair shape Disney hadn't created before.
Michelle: Making those shapes
on very, very long hair
and then trying to
figure out how to manage
those individual curl locks so they don't
poke through each other
and catch on each other.
Narrator: This task required Disney
to expand Tonic's tube-grooming tool,
giving it the ability to curl the hair up.
After sculpting the shape,
the team figured out
how the waves would move
and hold their look.
Nadim: Part of the trick
with something like wavy hair
or curly hair is retaining
the volume of the hair.
Because if you just sim it as is,
it'll just collapse and
fall flat on her head.
So how do you retain the flowiness of it?
Narrator: The team
developed what they called
an elastic rod model,
which determined the
degree to which the hair
would retain its twists and springiness
under different forces,
like wind or water.
Nadim: If, let's say, Moana
is falling through the sky
and her hair's really stretched, well,
how much of her hair is going
to be a full straight line
versus how much curl is going to be there?
Or if she compresses, how
much is it going to bunch up?
Narrator: But Disney also
wanted to give its animators
an ability to guide the
simulation of the hair.
So the engineers built a new
hair program, Quicksilver,
that combined rigging
and grooming controls.
Instead of animating the
characters with static hair,
now, the animators could put
the hair into starting poses,
and Quicksilver's engine
would use those poses
to determine the resulting movement.
By allowing artists to shape
the posing of the hair,
Disney was able to recover
some of the expressiveness
of hand-drawn animation that
could often get lost in CG.
It's particularly useful
for the interaction moments,
where the character is doing something
with their hair specifically,
and the animator wants to
guide what that's going to be.
Narrator: They wanted Moana in particular
to be able to constantly
play with her hair,
since that habit is typical of teenagers,
as they observed it in
actor Auli'i Cravalho
as she performed Moana's
lines in the studio.
The characters' darker hair
also broke new ground for Disney.
Nadim: If you look at
kind of previous movies,
"Tangled," "Frozen,"
we haven't really done
any black, darkish hair colors.
So that reacts fairly differently to light
than other hair colors,
and how do you kind of
still show its richness?
You kind of have to have a movie
that needs a hair color
to then be able to see
how far your technology
goes and then tune to that.
And now we're at a pretty good spot
with actually the shader
being able to handle
a wide range of hair colors.
Narrator: All of these
technologies and more
came into play in "Encanto."
The shading advancements from "Moana"
made it possible to get
the rich shades of hair
in the Madrigal family,
and the S-shaped curls
seen on Moana and Maui
appeared on some characters in "Encanto."
Jose: We had the software to be able to do
type 1 hair, type 2 hair very easily,
but we hadn't really figured out
how to do coils that are actually helical
and that actually look like springs.
Specifically for Mirabel,
she had kind of a type 3 curly hair,
like, loose ringlets
that get kind of tighter
in certain places.
Narrator: The team added this tighter type
of coil into Tonic.
Jose: So there was a lot of collaboration
with the technology team
trying to figure out what
is hair actually doing
when it starts to coil
versus when it's wavy
and then figuring out
how we can get our tools
to actually do that.
Narrator: Emphasizing
the unique attributes
of each hair type was a
big part of Jose's job
as a character look development artist.
Jose: We're trying to figure out,
what naturally is beautiful
about this type of hair
and how can we emphasize that?
Narrator: And the diversity
goes all the way down
to the individual hairs
on a character's head.
Curl direction is very important.
Because you don't want two
curls to look exactly the same,
because then it feels very artificial.
In everybody's hair,
there's a lot of variation.
Things like variety in size
of the curls, hair color.
We try to make sure that
nothing is symmetrical.
Narrator: Every strand
of hair also figured in
to the dance sequences of "Encanto,"
building on the movement work in "Moana."
The artists started by looking at
a lot of reference material,
including footage of the choreography.
Michelle: We knew that Mirabel and Luisa
and a lot of the characters
were going to be really active
and jumping around and in
a musical fantasy sequence
that they could be hanging upside down.
Sometimes in those tests,
you find out that, like,
one piece of hair is quite
a bit longer than the other.
And so you have to go
back in and adjust it.
Narrator: The team would
have to look at whether
all the strands of hair reacted naturally
to the character's
movements and to each other.
It was important as ever to
honor differences in textures
for every character.
Previously, Disney princesses
had mostly straight hair
that moved in big, sweeping paths.
To make more tightly curled hair
move naturally in "Encanto,"
the team had to adjust this approach.
Edna: We used to talk about
how, when they were dancing,
how the hair would have to move,
how the hair would have to perform.
For example, we have
the idea that Afro hair,
or African hair, has not movement.
And we have the perception
that that's something bad,
but that's not bad. It's just our hair.
Our hair doesn't have a lot of movement.
It's OK that it stay like that, you know?
So it doesn't have to be a ponytail
with straight hair to be beautiful.
Narrator: What set "Encanto"
apart from previous movies
was also the sheer scale
of its hair diversity,
not just for the Madrigal
family but for the entire town.
Edna: We have the 12 hair textures
in the 12 chapters of the family,
but also we have different styles
in the whole town in "Encanto."
You can see turbans.
You can see other type of braids.
More indigenous population,
for example, in Colombia.
There's a little girl in the town,
she has an Afro not like this
with turban, but all free.
And also you can find women with braids,
very Colombian and African style.
Narrator: Every single head of hair
had to be styled
meticulously by the artists,
picking up where they
left off with "Frozen."
Nadim: So if you watch
kind of the evolution
of having straight-hair characters,
and then suddenly "Encanto"
has all these crowd
characters with braids,
and we could barely do two-braid
characters on "Frozen."
So the advancements are really there,
and they trickle down.
Narrator: But at the start of production,
braiding hair was still
a very manual process.
Jose: So, like, how you would
actually braid actual hair
in real life, we have to do that
with essentially 3D tubes
that we use in our computer.
By the end of the movie,
we had a more automatic
process for making braids
where you just draw or you create a curve,
a line along the head where you
want your braid to come out,
and then it'll do a little
computer-made braid for you.
Narrator: That doesn't mean
all the work is finished.
Jose: There's so much diversity,
even within braid types,
that then there's more complex braids
that we're looking at to try to figure out
how to make those look really good.
Narrator: Ultimately,
"Encanto" made history
as the first Disney
animated movie to represent
the full range of hair
textures, from 1A to 4C;
a milestone reached by
building a foundation of tools
and then adapting them.
Nadim: What's also great about these tools
is we're able to repurpose them
in areas that you might not expect.
The system that we use to
do hair is the same system
that we use to do plenty of other things,
like Mirabel's dress.
Her skirt has tons and
tons of embroidery on it.
We were able to use iGroom to be able
to do some of the embroidery.
Narrator: The technological progress
is impressive on its
own, but it's always done
in service of telling bigger stories.
Michelle: I think now
at this point we have
a really complete set of tools,
and we should be able
to make and represent
the panoply of humanity,
which is a really good place to be.